today on the program we welcome back
someone who has not been with us for
several years dr. Paul Cameron who's the
chairman of the Family Research
Institute some of our viewers who have
been following the program for some time
dr. Cameron may remember you as one of
our most anti-gay guests that we've had
a lot of your work focused on the LGBT
community in different shapes and forms
and eventually in part two of the
interview I want to get to your more
general thoughts about the incredible
sort of increase in LGBT rights in the
US over the last many years but before
we get to that you reached out to me a
couple of weeks ago claiming that you
had been proven right on a few
particular LGBT predictions that you had
made most interestingly to me that you
predicted that there would be more and
more LGBT people over time and you
believe that that that is the case do
you not I do
I didn't predict that it would happen
necessarily but I did predict that if
our society or any society were to
equate homosexuality and heterosexuality
to make heterosexuality homosexuality as
attractive to tell its children one way
or the other
it's okay there would be an enormous
growth in homosexuality and I think but
this I'm not sure of the the increase in
LBGT LBG ISM is going to be unstoppable
unless society actually does something
to arrest it okay
so let's first describe how you are
measuring that there are more LGBT
people in society on what basis do you
say that well there are actually a
number of different polling
organizations pew Gallup and of course
the federal
government is running a number of
different polls usually under the CDC or
HHS and all of them show a dramatic
increase usually to about the same
magnitude that is in the aggregate about
a doubling since earlier polls not quite
as sophisticated in the 80s and early
90s so the latest iteration of a federal
government poll that I think is very
good is the one on drug use and so forth
and that one has something like 47,000
folk in it and there's been measuring
high school students in particular and
that of course is the area which is the
most likely to show an increase it's
it's the one that's most sensitive to
educational and media preachments and
that shows at least doubling okay so I I
don't I don't agree with you what what I
believe we are seeing is in most polls a
slight uptick and sometimes a level
number of people reporting that they are
LGBTQ I'll give you two data points and
of course as I always do you'll have
plenty of time to to refute them if you
look at Gallup numbers over the last
decade you've seen very modest increases
often within the margin of error for
example 3.8 percent in 2015 up to 4.5%
in 2018 that would be one data point a
second data point would be the National
Survey of family growth which is run by
the CDC that shows that for many surveys
all the way back to 2002 about 1.3
percent of respondents say that they are
gay or lesbian number who say they are
bisexual has varied a little bit over
time so I'm simply not even seeing if
the data you claim exists but I think
importantly there's a there's a really
key issue here which is there's a
difference between more people reporting
that they are LGBT versus more people
simply being willing
to tell the truth on surveys and a
stigma goes down it would make sense
that even without changing the
percentage of the population that is
LGBT that more people are just
comfortable saying that they are because
society has to some degree D stigmatized
it that's true that's possible however
that would seem to indicate that would
seemed yeah I would seem to indicate
that what we're looking at here is as
you say opening up telling the truth for
the first time that strikes me as
improbable because for instance if you
look back into the 80s where we did our
research and the 90s and so forth where
HIV and AIDS was very prevalent very
prevalent in the media the statistics
there are much smaller and I would argue
that we're looking a real increase
especially with the high school stuff
now to be sure how many of these high
schoolers will retain what they claim
how many of them will change as they
actually experience more of life and
engage in sexual activity it's possible
but I would put a lot of stake in this
risk factor survey that's been done now
for about twenty two three years yeah
well we'll get to the risk factor but it
sounds like what you're saying is you
are aware of some studies which seem to
show an increase in self-reported LGBT
membership I'm pointing to others which
show maybe a modest increase you're
accepting that at least some fraction of
that could simply be that society is
less likely to punish someone for just
saying honestly what it is that they
feel so it actually sounds like your
case that there has been this very clear
increase in the number of LGBT people
it's not a very strong case for someone
who claims to be a researcher I think
it's fairly strong first of all as you
admit just about every survey shows and
most of the surveys you're referring to
I suspect take the whole adult
population now I'm mainly concerned
about the green edge of the population
that is those in high school coming out
of high school into college and so forth
and by that basis it looks like about a
doubling and somewhat surprisingly to me
in some respects especially among
females yeah I mean listen but there has
not been a doubling in the number of
LGBT people there simply hasn't I think
maybe we could say because our audience
I think maybe is not interested in us so
much getting caught up in what what you
claim the numbers to be let's let's just
assume for a moment that there's been a
modest increase in the number of people
who say they are LGBT and I would
attribute the majority of that simply to
openness to admitting that because
society has distinct it the thing I
really want to get to which is a lot of
what you sent me is that you believe
that this actually imperils Homo sapiens
on the basis of reduced rates of
reproduction do you think at some point
homosexuality is going to cause homo
sapiens to die out it's possible now I
don't know we're rational people were
fairly rational that is at least and
maybe just maybe if the alarm is sounded
if people see the total fertility rate
declining precipitously if they see more
and more of their children going into
[ __ ] azzam or homosexuality sorry we
will because I apologize do something
what what strand ISM what's [ __ ] ism
that's the notion that somehow you're in
the wrong body that you have been
misplaced biologically that you're
psychologically really a girl even
though you're physiologically and
biologically a male why what as you say
why would people choose to go into that
like what benefits would it confer it
seems in fact to be extraordinarily
difficult both societally and medically
to do that why is that something
somebody would choose interestingly the
media has had a lot to do with this and
of course activist the the [ __ ]
activists that had a great deal to do
with this our society is complex people
who live in it are always looking for
reasons why they're not famous or
interesting or people aren't paying
enough attention to them aren't just
interested in what they have to say and
do and I'm afraid they're there we have
an incredibly documental increase
something from around one or two out of
10,000 perhaps in the 1980s to something
approximating almost two percent
according to latest CDC old high school
students well as your misstating the
pole the pole that that's not 2% of
people believe that they are transgender
but I think the interesting thing you
mentioned is you said that sometimes
people are looking for ways to get
famous how many famous transgender
people do you know of or could you name
well starting out with renee Richards I
guess in the 80s I recall and of course
and we have this this fellow Bruce
Jenner who's supposedly changing or
whatever way on the caitlyn now I had
his own TV program and so for it
apparently we are our children our high
schoolers are unusually susceptible to
what they see on TV what they're taught
in school and if they go to college or
university all this yeah but dr. hammer
another issue at a time if we can you
cited the idea of being famous as making
transgenderism appealing I asked you for
some names you went back to 1980 which
is 40 years ago named to people
of whom hold on one of whom was famous
long before they transitioned so that
doesn't seem like a very effective way
to get famous does it well I don't know
about famous but to give one a life
course to give one a reason to get up in
the morning to give one a special
attention anywhere you go different are
generally speak if you're a transsexual
you get attention now it may or may not
be positive but you're noticed and
people talk about you people look at you
okay but your first argument related to
being famous and now you're simply
saying it attracts attention in public
but but I want it so I there are there
are these interesting offshoots which
kind of give us insight into your
perspective but I want to go back to
what you said before which is it's
possible that the rate of LGBT
membership in Homo sapiens could
possibly was the word you used
cause the species to die out
homosexuality exists in hundreds or
thousands of species and the percentage
species that don't have culture in the
way that that humans do and it has not
had an impact on that the ability of
that species to continue to persist to
replicate we're not even close
mathematically even remotely to a
percentage of LGBT membership that would
even remotely imperil homo sapiens
particularly compared to the impact that
climate change decreased male sperm
count and so many other issues could
potentially have it seems that is
completely without any scientific basis
to suggest that well it's not a question
of scientific basis is a question of
things are changing which things that
are changing are having the most
profound effect and theoretically which
could for instance in our survey we
conducted in the early 80s we found that
the lb G's there were no T's then as you
recall reproduce at about a total
fertility rate of around point six you
need about two point one two
maintain the species in the aggregate
depending on whose total fertility rate
you take and it varies somewhat even
between governmental agencies much less
others who have independently tried to
calculate it somewhere between one point
eight seven perhaps to one point seven
seven right now for the United States
for Europe it's about one point five and
it's been staying fairly stable there
for the last few years
generally speaking across the world
there is the decrement especially in
what we might call Western civilization
in the total fertility rate and whatever
mistakes seem to be made in projections
all are to the leeward side that is
people seem to be under producing
compared to what we think they ought to
be given how they respond to
questionnaires and previous kinds of
fertility rates fertility is more
delicate than we have in the past
imagined
remember add an hour in 1962 said I'm
not gonna worry about this there'll
always be children well that's not
necessarily so when he said that the
fertility rate for Europe was close to
2.1 now it's about 1.5 no that takes the
whole aggregate it's a somewhat
different aggregate alike but as China
has demonstrated you mess with this for
about 40 years or so and we accommodate
that humans learn to not be as
interested in having multiple children
or even children dr. campaign Maya just
were getting soft track that the focus I
was hoping would be the idea that a
modest increase for example from three
point eight to four point five percent
of the population being LGBT simply
cannot mathematically make it so that it
is the responsible for
making the homosapiens potentially die
out I mean it simply is mathematically
impossible and it also culturally
doesn't make any sense
when you think about a Darwinian
adaptation and you consider that
homosexuality exists in hundreds and
thousands of species we are talking
about group level adaptations yes an
individual gay person or lesbian person
is mathematically far less likely to
reproduce but as a percentage as part of
a group as part of a society which has
had LGBT people for a very very long
time whether or not they identified that
way there is no mathematical basis for
your assertion and what China does with
a one-child policy or whatever is not
relevant to that I am disagree with you
first of all I'm not saying this is the
only factor obviously we're in a long
term fertility decline and it would not
take very many people going over to LGBT
if you would to dramatically affect how
many children are in the next generation
the one thing we can say for sure is
that unlike say global warming or
whatever whoever is crawling on our rugs
today definitely is going to shape the
future for tomorrow so we're in a
situation right now where even a an
incremental increase in kids who decide
to go into childless essentially
lifestyles are going to impact our
society dr. Cameron that also ignores
the fact that many people who aren't
LGBT don't have kids the idea that the
next generation is so highly sensitive
only to whether LGBT individuals aren't
having kids ignores the fact that the
sensitivity to that is much lower than
you would suggest because many people
not part of the LGBT community also
don't have children and you admit that
that's happening across multiple
cultures and in multiple countries but
we I think that
your position on that all right let's go
back you've brought up twice that you
think that many species have
homosexuality I don't think that I just
the truth I know it is not just the
truth homosexuality among humans is very
different than homosexuality in any
other context well you need it to use
you the people on your side damn
straight that it's different because
otherwise you lose the argument that
people are being convinced to be gay
that it's not actually different on the
contrary if you look at what animals do
let's take our own genus and you look at
what other animals do it looks like
homosexuality sometimes it involves sex
sometimes it's just in the case of
penguin sitting together on AIDS or
whatever homosexuality D humans is
pretty specific it is after all knowing
that there are the opposite sex
available in choosing the same sex it's
looking for sexual encounters and it's
often closing off the possibility of
sexual encounters with the opposite sex
obviously and like in our survey and I
think it's the only one that's actually
done an index of how many kids each lb G
claimed to have 0.6 is way below
replacement level the more that grows
the more it's going to influence a
declining total fertility rate dr.
Cameron you're always up with different
arguments that may be your point it's a
fully Hannibal point
dr. Cameron hold on a second in any you
could make the case that whatever is
different for humans because humans are
unique you could say child rearing it
might look like there are thousands of
species that do child rearing but it's
different for humans of course it is
humans are different and your are
now is to say that human homosexuality
is different than any other
homosexuality merely because humans are
human you could apply that to anything
but it doesn't refute the argument that
you're trying to refute I don't I don't
think that's true
I noticed of all you you can't interview
the animals you don't know what they're
thinking you don't know what their
choices are and these are unsalted but
but this is not science dr. Cameron dr.
Cameron this is no scientist I don't I
don't think there's any science on
homosexuality whether animal there is
you probably just don't like it no I
don't care dr. Dan has no heart you that
you're making actual scientists would
say you're creating into feasible
arguments it's sort of like saying I
don't care whether people say they are
atheists because deep down they actually
are religious they just don't even know
it these are the types of things that
are outside the realm of science because
they're unfalsifiable
you can't ask a dog whether they're
actually gay or just behaving in a way
that is indicative I mean this is that
this is not science I'm sorry it is
science that's why it's to extrapolate
human homosexuality or human marriage to
animals as I think silly yes or SunTrust
no burials animal animal behavior has no
bearing on how we are over in our
society our society is as we are now
demonstrating far more delicate than we
think your representative of a group
that's saying hey we can have as many
people as want to engage in
homosexuality it's not gonna hurt us
we're gonna fantasize or postulate that
it's kind of inborn people are naturally
responding to whatever they're finding
in themselves I'm saying not at all that
as a matter of fact we are social
animals we are social humans and as such
we are very susceptible apparently in
our
to the entertainment media what we see
on TV what we see on movies and who gets
attention there are I don't think but
maybe there are more disturbed more
distressed children today and more of
those seem to be opting for LBGT okay I
mean this is just a lion this is a pleat
disconnect from any I mean what you're
saying is just now so off the charts
that it's sort of like a Gish gallop
about choosing and and all of these
different things let's see if we can
because I think now it's very clear to
our audience sort of where you stand on
this stuff here's what I want to kind of
get to big picture with you as we're
getting now into the the latter part of
this interview what is it like given
that you have been working on this issue
for so long as I said you are one of the
the most well known sort of anti-gay
people I would say in American society
over the last many decades is it sad to
see that gay marriage is now legal all
over the country that more and more
states are making it illegal to fire
people because of their perceived or
actual sexual orientation as we learn
more and more about same-sex adoption we
see that the outcomes are just as good
as with opposite sex couple hold on a
second hold on I knew that one would set
you off we can focus in on the adoption
in a second but is it sad for you to see
that after decades of doing this that
things are clearly you're losing this
battle very clearly it's personally
distressing disappointing on the other
hand I I'm here because I feel that I
speak for the truth and eventually and
I'm afraid that our society is proving
it
you mess with homosexuality you're
messing with something that's far more
potent than you imagined you may like
the idea that hey people say I'm equal
to you because
well I have sex and I enjoy it and I
like it with more guys but I don't have
it with girls or seldom with girls or
whatever and that's fair that's
reasonable well it isn't fair and
reasonable if you want to continue to
have a society oh I get that stuff but
my question was that you you tell that
you've lost do you feel that you changed
it is epochal oh yeah I thought that's
feel that so let's say you told me in
one of our previous interviews that when
you were young you actually had a period
during which you experienced some
attractions to men I believe it was one
or a couple older men does this ring a
bell from one of our old interviews no
you missed here misrepresenting it I
said I was three years old and I was
raped by either a teenager or a young
man and at the time as I thought about
it I said as a three year old I could
see where this might catch on
fortunately for me it never happened
again had it happened again I don't know
I was three three is I remember some
things being three perhaps you do but
most of the stuff I remember is not
sexual but I do remember that sexual
event and it was something that
impressed itself on me and is that
partially responsible for your position
on gay adoption today something you are
so vehemently against I don't think so
but as I had done research and as you
may well be aware we've been doing
research now into Google child sexual
abuse on Google News we've collected an
enormous chunk of every single story
that Google presented for instance
between 2012 and 2014 here in the United
States child sexual abuse as indexed by
Google
hey if you can't believe Google who can
you believe in the United States about
half of all the child victims are
victims of homosexuals in the UK it's
running at about 75 percent okay done
this Cameron Mary I have to interrupt
I'm sorry I had to act early
I have to interrupt because you are that
this this is literal nonsense I mean
they're just there's a couple things
that are just being completely misstated
by you number one we know that when it
comes to pedophilia it is not an act
that is sexual in terms of heterosexual
or homosexual
it is often based on availability not
and anything that is going on cycle
articles what is reported on Google dr.
Camry he dr. Cameron hey hold on a
second here
well there are no rape enjoyed
homosexuality he knew what he was doing
dr. K I didn't know it any analysis of
the frequency of a phenomena on the
basis of the frequency with which the
media reports on it is going to be
skewed by how interesting it is to
report on it for media and that is not a
serious way to determine the frequency
of an event okay I would disagree with
you in general that first of all I agree
the media does what's interesting what
they think will get attention
however for instance when it comes to
say clerics what we found is that
Baptists across all these surveys that
we've done who are clerks who do mola
stations only about 43 percent of the
perpetrators are engaged in
homosexuality with children whereas with
Roman Catholic priests it's somewhere in
the vicinity of oh hi
these low 90s depending on the situation
and the culture now here there's no
reason at all why given the hostility
generally to religion by the press
always interested in highlighting
hypocrisy and nastiness on their part
what we found is this cross as near as
we can tell every society the ease is
English and even though societies that
use Chinese and polish and Italian and
so forth a Protestant ministers tend
more frequently to molest girls and
Catholic priests in every society that
we've been able to index for a
reasonable length of time our after boys
now I would say not that the homosexual
that they're people who engage in sex
with children are pedophilia acts wool
they are engaging in sex with children
they do it because they like it almost
all of them also engage with man with
men twenty years I mean this is a so
widely debunked that I can't even my
audience is just so beyond this you know
I was really hoping to hear from you
your honest feelings about how your
movement is losing its losing every year
its losing ground as well GBC and are
most interested in Johnson even science
well you can say what science is the
collection of and theorizing about piles
of data of varying sorts
that's what science is now if we have an
enormous pile of data collected from
Google when we've tried to collect it
ourselves we were always open to the to
the charge well you may be biased and
then what you're looking for or looking
at
maybe you ignored certain stories and so
forth now we found a general consistency
and I'm pointing out one of them or look
at school teachers likewise
among those who elementary teachers who
molest children and again this is I'm
going to stick with Google News they are
on the amount of children that each
perpetrator reaches is about the same
for heterosexual as well as homosexual
molesters but once you get to the
secondary level high school suddenly
there is about a doubling of the number
of students who are molested by the
homosexual incline versus those harrison
dr. Cameron I am sorry I have to cut
this I just I have to cut this up this
is this is like this is like deciding
which dogs are more dangerous based on
which dogs are more written about as
being involved in bites I mean it's just
it's the most wide I can't believe that
someone who claims to be a man of
science like you in 2019 is is still
doing this stuff and unfortunately
because of the filibustering on this
stuff we're at the end of our time and I
was hoping to really be able to dig in
with you more about how you're feeling
about everything that has taken place
rather than the time I mean I was
arguing about this stuff with you ten
years ago when it didn't make sense then
and it still doesn't make sense now but
it seems as though it does make sense
now for instance as we've gathered data
how do you account for this doing the
same thing in Mandarin for China we have
a pretty good sample 200 consecutive
cases of molestation according to Google
and Mandarin and China which is far more
accepting of LGBT ism in China not no
China is not accepting of LGBT ISM and
China has a completely closed suppressed
media state and the idea of Google
China News in order to ascertain
anything about that society is one of
the silliest things that anyone can do
listen doc you can break it selling
we're you go to Taiwan and we got to
Taiwan by using the Taiwanese dialect
and doing the same thing it kicks up
okay if we and we've also done it in
Russia we've done it in Poland we've
done it in Italy and the the consistency
between for instance the Pew survey
people and how that's a favorably
inclined they are to homosexuality and
the proportion of their children who are
molested according to Google which are
homosexual he molested is that's about
point seven point eight is a very recent
correlation I think we get way over time
dr. Cameron dr. Paul Cameron chairman of
the Family Research Institute I I'm
sorry we weren't able to have the the
type of conversation I wanted and we're
going back to the same tired arguments
but I think at least we've been able to
do de them you're still after the same
stuff usually the same stuff and we
appreciate dr. Paul Cameron joining us
today